« Mais qu’est-ce qu’il fait ?! »
Ça fait déjà un bout de temps que le
manuscrit d’Ainsi parlait Zarathoustra
a été remis à l’imprimeur, et le livre
n’est toujours pas en vente.
Nietzsche, qui a environ 40 ans,
s’impatiente et ne comprend pas.
Et qu’est-ce qu’il apprend ?
En fait, l’imprimeur a volontairement
laissé de côté le manuscrit !
Il veut d’abord satisfaire une commande urgente
de 500 000 recueils de cantiques, qui doivent
être livrés à temps pour Pâques.
Bien sûr, Nietzsche est énervé.
Mais il trouve aussi la situation comique :
lui, que certains appellent « l’Antéchrist »,
l’auteur de la formule « Dieu est
mort », se fait passer devant par une
compilation de chants religieux !
Une trentaine d’années plus tard,
c’est la Première Guerre mondiale.
Pour soutenir les valeurs morales des
soldats allemands, le haut commandement militaire
leur fait distribuer le Nouveau Testament.
Mais ce n’est pas le seul livre
que les soldats reçoivent.
Ils reçoivent également… Ainsi parlait
Zarathoustra de Nietzsche.
L’armée allemande a fait imprimer
150 000 exemplaires.
Ce qui s’est passé avec Nietzsche est inédit
dans l’histoire de la pensée moderne.
Sa philosophie est rejetée
pendant toute sa vie.
Puis elle connaît un décollage
dans ses 10 dernières années.
Et enfin, après sa mort en 1900, sa philosophie
devient purement et simplement une des plus
influentes du XXe siècle.
Nietzsche est aujourd’hui le
philosophe moderne le plus populaire.
Sa tête, avec sa moustache et ses lunettes,
est une image familière, presque
un symbole de la pensée.
Comment expliquer que des livres qui pourissaient
dans les entrepôts du vivant de l’auteur soient
aujourd’hui de perpétuels best-sellers
— et même bien plus que ça, des chefs-d’œuvre et
des symboles de la civilisation occidentale ?
La réponse à cette question est
dans LA VIE de Nietzsche.
Écoutez-moi jusqu’au bout, et vous comprendrez
pourquoi et comment s’est produit le plus grand
come-back de la philosophie moderne.
Quand Ludwig Nietzsche se met à jouer du
piano, son tout jeune fils Friedrich laisse
tomber ce avec quoi il est en train de jouer
et écoute avec une attention captivée.
Son père est le seul dans le village à
extraire de si beaux sons de l’instrument.
Ça le place au-dessus des simples
mortels pour le jeune Friedrich.
C’est déjà comme ça, par son talent de pianiste,
que Ludwig Nietzsche avait séduit la famille de sa
femme, la mère du futur philosophe.
Et ce n’est pas son seul talent.
En tant que précepteur, Ludwig Nietzsche
s’était fait remarquer pour son savoir.
Il savait le latin, le grec, et
se débrouillait en français.
Il faut dire qu’il était lui-même le fils
d’un pasteur intellectuellement talentueux
(le grand-père du philosophe, donc).
Après avoir été précepteur dans des
familles princières pendant 7 ans,
Ludwig, le père du philosophe,
devient à son tour pasteur,
pour une communauté regroupant
trois villages près de Leipzig.
Ce que montre cette anecdote, c’est que le talent
de Nietzsche ne vient pas de nulle part.
Il hérite son talent musical de son père.
Comme lui, il sera un pianiste accompli.
Mais surtout, Nietzsche descend de deux hommes,
deux pasteurs, son père et son
grand-père, qui se distinguent
par leur supériorité intellectuelle.
Si l’enfant Nietzsche admire son paternel,
il n’en reçoit pas une influence durable :
son père meurt quand il a seulement 5 ans.
Mais il continue de grandir dans un
milieu où le savoir est valorisé.
Sa mère déménage pour se
rapprocher de sa famille.
Les membres de cette famille, qui appartiennent
à la bourgeoisie intellectuelle — il
y a notamment des avocats
— la famille maternelle supervise
l’éducation du jeune Nietzsche.
Nous sommes en septembre 1858.
Le destin du jeune Nietzsche, qui a
presque 14 ans, angoisse sa mère.
Sa famille veut envoyer son fils dans une
école pour orphelins, mais elle refuse.
La chance lui sourit : les excellents résultats
scolaires de Nietzsche attirent l’attention du
recteur du prestigieux internat de
Pforta, qui accueille les meilleurs
élèves de toute l’Allemagne.
Nietzsche obtient une bourse.
Son avenir scolaire est assuré.
Et pas n’importe quel avenir scolaire : 6
ans de formation intellectuelle très intense.
Madame de Staël, l’autrice française du tournant
du XIXe siècle qui a lancé le romantisme français
à partir du romantisme allemand — Madame de Staël
a dit à propos de la formation intellectuelle
en Allemagne : « Ce que l'on appelle étude en
Allemagne est véritablement admirable.
Quinze heures par jour de solitude
et de travail pendant des années leur
semblent un mode de vie normal. »
La mère de Nietzsche, qui est une fille de la
campagne, l’avait habitué à se lever tôt (vers
5 heures du matin)
— mais à Pforta,
le lever commence à 4 heures du matin.
Peu après 5 heures du matin, les élèves doivent
être assis dans leurs salles d’étude.
Et puis ils se mettent à faire du latin,
du grec, et de l’allemand (principalement) avec un
niveau d’exigence qu’ils n’ont jamais connu.
Nietzsche est un des tout meilleurs.
Non seulement il est intellectuellement doué et
travailleur, mais il est aussi curieux.
Il ne se contente pas des
œuvres au programme.
Ce sont ces intenses années d’étude à
Pforta qui donnent à Nietzsche le fonds culturel
et intellectuel pour être un grand penseur.
Il en tire également — comme les élèves passés par
la classe préparatoire en France — une discipline
et une capacité de travail supérieures.
Dans la quarantaine, son mode de vie spartiate
étonne encore les hôteliers.
Il se lève chaque matin avant
l’aube pour se laver à l’eau froide, avant
d’abattre plusieurs heures d’écriture.
À 21 ans, Nietzsche étudie la philologie
— c’est-à-dire l’étude critique des textes
anciens — à 21 ans, Nietzsche étudie la
philologie à l’université de Leipzig.
Le propriétaire de son logement a une
boutique de livres d’occasion.
Un jour que Nietzsche fouine dans cette
boutique, il tombe sur Le monde comme volonté
et comme représentation de Schopenhauer.
Il le feuillette d’abord distraitement.
Puis il commence à lire, captivé.
Le style est tellement plus lisible que
celui de Kant ou Hegel.
Et puis il y a une familiarité
dans le ton qui fascine Nietzsche.
De retour chez lui, il se pose sur son canapé,
et se plonge dans Le monde comme
volonté et comme représentation.
Comme beaucoup de gens, Nietzsche est
transformé par cette lecture.
Sa vision du monde et de
l’existence s’écroule.
Pendant plusieurs semaines, il s’abandonne à une
orgie d’autocritique en remplissant un journal
de pensées haineuses contre lui-même.
Il est proche de la folie — mais heureusement,
sa discipline le sauve.
La découverte de Schopenhauer
est un tournant intellectuel décisif.
Et c’est également le cas pour plusieurs
des amis de Nietzsche
— et plus généralement pour
beaucoup d’Allemands de sa génération.
Pour Nietzsche comme pour la plupart,
la dépression liée à la découverte de
la vision du monde schopenhauerienne
ne dure que quelques semaines.
Mais Schopenhauer devient ensuite une
sorte de demi-dieu intellectuel
pour le jeune Nietzsche.
Il dit que c’est le meilleur philosophe
des 1000 dernières années.
Il garde Le monde comme volonté et comme
représentation et Parerga et paralipomena auprès
de lui, et il les consulte comme une Bible.
Comment résumer l’influence de Schopenhauer sur
Nietzsche ?
Tout d’abord,
Nietzsche se met à voir le monde comme un ensemble
d’appétits conflictuels dépourvu de sens.
Ensuite, il adopte le mépris de Schopenhauer
pour les profs et les universitaires.
Et enfin, Schopenhauer lui inspire le désir
d’élaborer sa propre philosophie originale.
C’est d’ailleurs en élaborant sa propre pensée que
Nietzsche se détachera plus tard de Schopenhauer
et des fans de Schopenhauer.
Mais ça n’efface pas sa dette.
L’influence de l’auteur du Monde comme volonté
et comme représentation a été décisive dans le
destin de Nietzsche.
Sans Schopenhauer,
nous n’aurions pas eu Nietzsche.
À 24 ans, Nietzsche, qui vient de terminer
ses études à Leipzig, est invité à un dîner en
comité restreint autour de Richard Wagner.
Wagner, qui a 55 ans, est déjà un compositeur
célèbre pour ses opéras grandioses.
Pour Nietzsche, c’est une
rencontre incroyable.
Il est passionné de musique — mais surtout, il
a déjà acheté des partitions de Wagner ;
il les a étudiées, et il a été très
impressionné par le style du compositeur.
Bref, il est fan, et là il dîne
avec le maître lui-même.
Comme Nietzsche a une connaissance approfondie
de son travail, la séduction est réciproque.
Mais il y a autre chose :
à un moment de leur discussion,
Wagner se met à lui parler de Schopenhauer,
le seul philosophe — selon lui — à avoir compris
la véritable nature de la musique.
Wagner dit à Nietzsche qu’il doit
beaucoup à Schopenhauer.